Speaker 1: It is Election Day 2022. And as is
often the case on election days in the United
States, everyone has their take, everyone has
their view. Everyone likes to say this is the one
thing that this is really all about. It's really
you know, in times past, it's really a referendum
on Trump or this is really about corporations
versus individuals or whatever. And almost always
there really is no one thing. And so I've resisted
that type of language, but this time there really
kind of is the one big thing, the one big thing
at stake here today is are we going to make a move
in the direction of being for democracy, where
the candidate that gets the most votes wins and
assumes office without controversy? Or are we
going to make another move away from democracy
where even if you don't get the most votes people
claim, you should still assume the office you
ran for. And they may even be able to make it a
reality if we aren't careful and if we don't make
the correct votes today. That is fundamentally
what today's election is about. Imagine 20, 50,
100 years from now, and think about today as an
inflection point. One story that could be told is,
well, Trump came to power in 2016. He was defeated
in 2020 after a very dangerous four years of
insanity. And then the MAGA movement moved in
in 2022, took over the Senate and or House,
a bunch of the governors houses. Then as a
result of that, was able to steal an election
in 2024 leading to the end of American democracy
as we knew it in 2028 and on downhill from there.
Right. That's one story that if we think about
today is an inflection point could be told 20,
50, 100 years from now. There's a different
story which could be told again because it's an
inflection point. It could be. Trump did come to
power in 2016 and then was defeated in 2020 after
that very same dangerous four years of insanity.
But then in 2022, a little bit of sanity returned.
There's still tens of millions of lunatics,
and we see them all the time, but a little
bit. Just enough sanity returned that the tens of
millions of anti-democracy lunatics were defeated
on November 8th, 2020 to absolute disaster was
just barely averted. And then things got on to
a more logical path in 26 and 24, 26, 28, etc.
It's a divergence point, it's an inflection point,
and those are two possible stories that could be
told. Consider these contrasts. Rolling Stones,
as a winsome saying and Patrick Rice are reporting
that, quote, Trump is calling Republicans to ask
how many times they will impeach Biden if they win
tonight. Think of that. Now, on the other hand,
Joe Biden and Barack Obama have been touring the
country saying we need to save democracy. This
is not fundamentally about should the top tax
rate on the richest Americans be 35, 37 or 39%?
That's a question. It's a perfectly reasonable
question. And at times past, we talked a lot about
questions like that. We're dealing with something
very different here. Okay. Now, by the way, in the
meantime, Joe Biden is predicting that Democrats
win on the basis of an improving economy. That's
also possible. We just don't know. Based on the
polling right now, the pollsters really don't
know. And we're going to talk about that next. But
before we do that, I really hope every single one
of you that votes in the United States has already
voted or is planning to vote. And I keep getting
this in my email. David, I care about what's
happening, but one vote never makes a difference.
These elections never come down to one vote, so
it's really hard to feel like my vote actually
matters. And I've been talking about this on our
screens lately. I understand that feeling. I think
the same thing. What? When has a gubernatorial
race or a Senate race come down to a single vote?
Therefore, my vote doesn't matter wrong. The
way you have to think about it is as follows.
Tons of people have that thought. Tons of people
consider staying home because it never comes down
to one vote and they all say, my vote isn't going
to make the difference here. Think about that as
a group you're a part of. And once you think about
it that way, elections often come down to do. The
people who wonder, Is my vote going to make a
difference? Does that constituency, does that
group stay home or vote? We all have that thought.
If every one of us who thought it never comes down
to have one vote, I'll stay home. If we all do
stay home, we lose a bunch of elections that
we could win. Okay, so don't fall for my vote.
Doesn't make a difference. That's another way
that these right wingers like to suppress the
vote. Don't let them do it. We'll have results
live tonight on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook
starting at 730 Eastern, 430 on the West Coast